bravo à la propagande de guerre
occidentale ça marche vraiment à
merveille la ligne atlantiste et bien
suivi partout bon il ya des petits
couacs parfois quand les autorités
ukrainiennes 10,1 même qu'en fait il n'y
a pas de profondeur d'agents russes
imminente c'est une niche de
nous ne voyons pas de fondement pour
dire qu'une offensive d'envergure sur le
cren se prépare même physiquement ça ne
peut pas se produire y at il des
mouvements de forces armées russes sur
le territoire de la fédération de russie
où il y en a nous en prenons note ce
n'est pas nouveau pour nous c'est
peut-être nouveau pour nos partenaires
étrangers qui ont finalement vu qu'il y
avait des forces et qu'elle était
déplacé d'une certaine manière cette
situation a commencé le 30 octobre avec
un article du washington post j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que les
représentants de ce respectable médias
se sont adressés à - le jour même avec
des informations sur de prétendues
rassemblement de forces sur nos
frontières je souligne encore une fois
que je répondu le 30 octobre que nous ne
voyons rien de ce genre cela a été
enregistré un marché kardono
mais bien sûr dans ce camp là c'est
toujours l'oncle sam qui a raison le
gouvernement et craignant d'y à son
peuple qu'une invasion russe n'est pas
imminente les etats unis sont ils
d'accord avec cette évaluation
une invasion n'est pas imminente
eh bien personne ne peut pénétrer
l'esprit du président poutine - des
dirigeants russes nous savions tous que
c'est le cas et concernant la situation
sur place ok ce qu'on est bien servi
voilà par exemple cet article poignant
du touch sur une pauvre mère de famille
qui a dû s'acheter un fusil d'assaut et
de l'équipement militaire pour repousser
l'attaqué russe
c'est notre foyer des ukrainiens
ordinaire prennent les armes alors que
vladimir poutine rassemble des troupes à
moins de 100 km de la capitale certains
citoyens décident de prendre le problème
en main cette femme qu'on nous présente
comme une spécialiste en études de
marché
si on bezoom on peut la photo n'a
clairement pas d'argent pour réparer sa
cuisine depuis un moment mais sachez de
l'équipement militaire pour des milliers
de dollars et en plus et les membres des
forces de défense territoriale une
ukrainienne ordinaire vous dites même
les revue d'économie s'y mettent des
économistes qui nous explique comment
faudrait-il utiliser les systèmes anti
xa américains et britanniques contre les
russes la revue quand même légèrement
surprise du fait que les ukrainiens sont
trop relax par rapport à cette invasion
russe qui se passera demain ils n'ont
pas dû à 6 écoutez madame c'est qui
encore un petit bijou un reportage sur
deux britanniques qui se battent dans
les tranchées ukrainienne contre
l'invasion russe crise ukrainienne ces
britanniques qui se battent dans les
tranchées contre les russes après s'être
lancé dans une nouvelle vie c'est le
vice-représentant permanent russe auprès
de l'onu dmitry polanski qui a pointé du
doigt que la présence de mercenaires
étrangers dans le dôme basse constitue
une violation directe des accords de
misc lors d'une interview à sky news
malheureusement cette interview n'a
jamais été diffusée bizarre non encore
un journaliste américain de buzz fit
news sur vela report john yates que via
un viseur optique et raconte les erreurs
du front aéroport de dounia sq contrôlée
par des forces soutenues par la russie
je n'en ai jamais été aussi proches ces
dernières années perçue à travers la
longue vue d'un soldat ukrainien depuis
la ligne de front au coucher du soleil
aujourd'hui les forces pro russes il
faut encore usage de l'artillerie lourde
de temps en temps ils ont utilisé un
lance-grenade automatique quand j'étais
là-bas
sauf que sur twitter on a vu la même
image un peu différemment d'après ce que
je vois il utilise aussi des grues
utiliser rillieux vous des grues et
qu'on seriez-vous quoi que ce soit si
vous saviez qu'une guerre à grande
échelle est imminente en effet on y voit
des grues quelqu'un peut dire si elles
sont utilisées c'est bien les efforts
conjoints quand tout le monde travaille
à l'unisson dans un but commun sauf que
dans ce cas précis ce but commun des
médias occidentaux prête bien moins
sourire c'est de faire éclater la guerre